[Music]
hello there
you could be exactly who the EU
institutions need for their
international security we're looking for
highly talented and motivated officers
and assistants in the fields of security
operations technical security and
information and document security as a
security officer your principal function
will be to ensure the security of
persons buildings and sensitive and
classified information
this can include analyzing threats and
risks coordinating teams and projects
and coordinating security awareness
activities as a security assistant all
assist in the operational aspects you'll
have to perform duties on a rotor system
outside of office hours as well as
standby duties working for the EU you
all have the chance to broaden your
learning enhance your skills and develop
your career you'll be part of one of the
multicultural international and diverse
teams working together to enhance the
lives of 500 million EU citizens and
beyond does this sound like a perfect
fit for you and do you meet the
eligibility criteria apply now for more
information on the requirements and
selection procedure visit security dot
EU - careers dot EU shaping europe
together